right well done  three minutes yeah what you need  [Music]  good evening boss  [Music]  no way we all get through this if even  one tin soldiers left standing we've  lost it's gonna be blood on the floor I  got no plans tomorrow night I get first  crack at the big guy iron man's when  he's waiting for that's true he hates  you the most  Ultron knows we're coming  odds are we'll be riding into heavy fire  and that's what we signed up for but the  people of sokovia they didn't so our  priority is getting them out all they  want is to live their lives in peace and  that's not gonna happen today but we can  do our best to protect them and we can  get the job done  and find out what Ultron's been building  we find Romanoff and we clear the field  keep the fight between us  [Music]  Ultron thinks we're monsters and we  what's wrong with the world this isn't  just about beating him it's about  whether he's right  [Music]  you